the police prefect of paris is accused
of breaking the law after allegedly
ordering the preventative arrest of
suspected yellow vest activists
according to recently released documents
out then detailing instructions for
checking people arriving in the french
capital
officers were apparently told to arrest
individuals who matched a thug
profile and to confiscate any objects
then that could potentially be used as
weapons
they were also ordered to carry out
identity checks and vehicle searches
the orders were apparently first issued
back in 2019
by the previous prefect but have since
been renewed
under french law though preventative
detention is illegal
human rights groups are outraged by the
revelations
this is very serious we have documented
the fact that thousands of people have
been arrested
and sometimes prosecuted without having
committed any violent act
which obstructs the right to peaceful
protest
the revelation comes as yellow vest
protest in france return after the
covert lockdown the
movement initially began in late 2018 as
a recap in protest over
fuel price hikes and high living costs
and has developed since
many of their rallies have resulted in
violence thousands of demonstrators and
police officers have been injured and
over
a dozen people have lost their lives we
spoke to one french lawyer who says that
preventative rests do lead to innocent
people being detained
since the start of the yellow vest
movement protesters have been facing the
problem of preventive arrests and body
searches
what does it mean in general how do you
put out a fire or lower the flames
therefore you preventively take away
some people from the demonstration
either before the start of the
demonstration or right at the moment
crowds start to form
people are being chosen randomly and
anyone can be detained without reason
by the way some have been detained for
just being in the wrong place at the
wrong time
and it later turned out they had nothing
to do with the movement at all
france's arrest and pre-trial detention
system has been turned on its head
law enforcement officers pursue the
principle that a person will do
something
even without any wrongdoing if you are
sitting on a bench a few meters from
where a demonstration is about to start
it is supposed to might illegally join
the rally and then turn violent
you